اعلن حزب الله ان مقاتليه قصفوا بالاسلحه
المناسبه احد المباني السكنيه في مستوطنه
افيفيم شمالي اسرائيل واوقع اصابات مؤكده
وقال الحزب ان مقاتليه اصابوا بشكل مباشر
مرابطه للجيش الاسرائيلي في ديشون
واستهدفوا ايضا موقع الظهير العسكري وقلعه
هونين وافاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق اربعه
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه موقع عسكري
اسرائيلي في مزارع شبع
المحتله اعلن المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي استكمال تنفيذ سلسله هجمات
جويه على الاراضي اللبنانيه شملت مواقع
يعتبرها الجيش عسكريه وبنا تحتيه تابعه
لحزب الله وقال انه جرى رصد عمليه اطلاق
للصواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مزارع شبعه
ورامت نفتالي في الجليل الاعلى دون وقوع
اصابات كما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوع
اصابه مباشره بصاروخ مضاد للدبابات على
منزل في مستوطنه افيفيم وقد رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاله التاهب الامني في الجبهه
الشماليه عبر اغلاق الشوارع المؤديه الى
البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه القريبه من
لبنان